despite all the sanctions the Russian
Ruble is one of the best performing
currencies in the world one of the top
reasons that the ruble is doing so well
is because many of the sanctions imposed
on Russia aren't even that effective
especially the energy sanctions you see
it the European Union is way more
dependent on Russian energy than they
would like to admit and though I'm sure
many of them would like to ban Russian
Imports completely this is simply not
realistic here's the thing Russia is the
world's largest gas exporter and the
second largest all exporter so it's not
really possible to completely cut off
Russian exports overnight